Henry you are the like there must be so
many actors watching this this shown
watching this couch and like Hollywood
really messed with your head I mean they
nearly gave you the big gig so many
times yeah yeah there was I mean
Superman was one of them oh the first
time around yeah yeah bond was another
one and now I want both yeah essentially
I got close to a bunch of stuff and and
didn't get it but it's funny that people
think that's a bad thing we're in
Hollywood
everyone's auditioning or in the acting
industry everyone's trying to get a role
and they're not necessarily getting them
and so to get an opportunity to be in
the limelight by missing out on the big
roles it's actually a good thing as
opposed to a bad thing and I count my
lucky stars each one of those okay
turning it into a positive it sounds
quite ships my profile who never works
wasn't written for you oh well hey I
don't know we can go that far oh you can
I think the writer of the books when the
movie came around I think I was her
first choice I think that's the rumor I
heard and she wanted me to play the role
but it wasn't up to her and instead yeah
very talented actually played a thing
Wow
[Laughter]
not that he's angry wealthy and famous
nameless in Twilight all the Twilight's
he's in the field the remake
[Music]